here's somebody right here here's
somebody i thought from nick's library
right here
i'm just joking here's a here's a
beautiful young fellow with his child
right here
what up king of this thing this is a mud
coming at you from erie pennsylvania
i got a king in her stinger for you
breast milk
i know a lot of bodybuilders drink that
[ __ ] oh they do and i'm honestly
starting to believe it
i mean look at this dude he's ripped
jacked
yeah oh yep better call baby you saw it
on his little
yeah get going snitch sniffing around
that baby right now
i want him tested twice a week that's
what i'm saying man
i tell jeff novitskiy come to the crib
dude bossing getting too big man i don't
trust this
his mom's putting something in this
juice box you feel me
uh breast milk i'd have a little man i'm
not having a lot i'll probably pass and
i don't like
any uh male i don't like dairy i don't
like milk
yeah you've got to but he's talking
about breast milk man he's talking about
you know what i'm saying that now some
of them freaks out there will suck on a
girl's breast
for the milk
i'll probably sing it too but dude if
you try and get them gained
summer's coming up trying to get them
gained and so because i guess there's a
lot of igf-1
in breast milk and like growth hormone
for the baby so if you're trying to
you know be mr olympia yeah shake your
tissue there you go there you go
now i feel like back in the day maybe
sipped a little breast milk dude i'm not
gonna lie i paid a premium for it as
well
dude if i drank it i'd drink it right at
the end of a damn needle bro
okay
do you know much easier to see his
steroids then it is easier to sneak into
a pregnant woman's house
it's a lot it sucks it's a lot it's a
lot
it's a lot how bad you want it man you
want to be slow how bad you want it bro
dude this ain't nick's library where you
should just
get whatever you want okay nate tells on
you
nick is so pissed we keep bringing up
his library the la crosse public library
run won awards in wisconsin every year
[Laughter]
he's so proud of that dude every library
won awards bro
it's a freaking library
dude the library is already insane man
the libraries are insane all right
i can't hear the teacher i come around
and go yeah god dang
conversation we would have a full
launch spread in the [ __ ] sit on the
carpet of the library
it's like what the [ __ ] are y'all
see the [ __ ] camping trip she we
would be there when she
opened the library doors and the lady
and we would straight up be there man
and every now and then a hot chick would
come to the library yeah that's all you
could focus so rare yeah
[Music]